und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka abt
am tag danach ist die kommentierung der
wahlergebnisse wie so oft eine frage des
blickwinkels
die einen sind entsetzt darüber dass in
brandenburg fast ein viertel und in
sachsen sogar mehr als 27 prozent der
wähler fw gewählt habe deren
spitzenpersonal in beiden ländern keine
hemmungen gegenüber dem radikal
völkischen parteiflügel sagt andere
betonen lieber das sich immerhin zwei
drittel der wähler dem klar entgegen
gestellt haben und es so den jeweils
amtierenden ministerpräsidenten
ermöglichen irgendwie weiter zu regieren
diese positive positivere perspektive
bevorzugen vor allem die vertreter von
cdu und spd die cdu schaut erleichtert
nach sachsen
die spd nach brandenburg und so hat
jeder der berliner großkoalitionäre
etwas womit er sich trösten kann klaus
brodbeck berichtet der tag danach bei
der cdu erleichterung politisches wunden
lecken und selbstkritik wir haben auch
gewusst dass das jahr 2019 kein
einfaches jahr für uns ist dass es ein
hürdenlauf ist und der wahrheit gehört
manche dieser hürden haben wir auch
nicht so genommen wie wir uns das selbst
vorgenommen haben
applaus für die kameras so harmonisch
aber dürfte es kaum weiter gegangen sein
eine äußerung der vorsitzenden teile der
afg wählerschaft künftig womöglich außen
vor zu lassen sorgt für ärger wir
verzichten auf überhaupt keine
wählerstimmen
ich habe immer gesagt ich bin der
ministerpräsident aller sachsen und ich
mache nur nicht alles mit weil wir als
volkspartei immer den anspruch haben
müssen wähler an uns zu binden und wenn
wir wieder verlieren den wahlen haben
wir die aufgabe zur nächsten wahl diese
wähler zurückzugewinnen
kramp-karrenbauer muss relativieren und
zugleich vorgeben wie umgehen mit der
konkurrenz
brand wir machen politik für alle
wählerinnen und wähler egal ob sie uns
ihre stimme gegeben haben oder nicht
aber gleichzeitig halten wir den kurs
der klaren abgrenzung zur afg und
deswegen gilt auch weiter der beschluss
dass es mit der afg keine regierung
geben wird
feier laune bei den grünen nicht nur
weil robert habe gerade geburtstag hat
wieder mal konnten sie ihre
machtoptionen deutlich ausweiten
nur wenn man mit anpackt kann man auch
verändern und deswegen gehen wir jetzt
natürlich in gesprächen mit rein
aber das wird ein weiter weg grad in
sachsen auch ein harter weg weil wir bei
vielen fragen weit auseinander sind
aber demokratie ist nicht einfach ganz
anders die laune bei der linken blumen
jahr aber die rolle als alleinige
vertreterin der ost interessen ist
verloren
das spitzenpersonal politisch in hoher
gefahr
was uns als linke jetzt nicht hilft und
was den menschen für und mit den wir
politik machen nicht hilft ist wenn wir
jetzt so ein modell reflexhaft display
geben also reflexhafte schuldzuweisungen
oder das modell schlachteplatte fahren
noch triste ist es heute für die fdp
zweimal nicht reingekommen bei den
liberalen mischen sich trauer und trotz
wir hängen unser fähnchen nicht nach dem
wind und sagen ach so jetzt müssen wir
die ja völlig anders machen als vorher
gemischte gefühle bei der spd
brandenburg gerade noch verteidigt in
sachsen weit abgeschlagen
erklärungsversuche heute mal ohne
schuldzuweisung an die große koalition
was heißt das wahlergebnis von gestern
dieses wahlergebnis heißt für alle
demokratischen kräfte
das ost themen stärker ernst genommen
werden ich glaube es nervt uns und die
menschen im lande dass in der spd immer
nach wie vor über die große koalition
gejammert wird statt wirklich daran zu
arbeiten dieses land voranzubringen
dann koalitionsausschuss der schreck der
landtagswahlen könnte das bündnis im
bund zunächst stabilisieren auf beiden
seiten
schauen wir uns die beiden ländern noch
mal einzeln an
am tag danach in sachsen markt die
erleichterung der cdu noch so groß sein
dass sie sich als stärkste kraft
behauptet hat aber unterm strich stehen
da trotzdem herbe verluste und für die
fortsetzung einer großen koalition
reicht es nicht mehr
das amtliche endergebnis für sachsen
sieht jetzt wie folgt aus die cdu kommt
auf 32,1 prozent die fdp liegt bei 27,5
die linke bei 10,4 die grünen erzielen
8,6 die spd nur noch 7,7 prozent die fdp
schafft es mit 4,5 genauso wenig in den
landtag wie freien wähler
soweit die zahlen aber was steht
dahinter und wie geht es jetzt weiter
eindrücke aus sachsen von stefan kennt
eine schmuckstück siedlung im landkreis
meißen ins ritz west ein stückchen heile
welt von wegen
hier hat der frust die wahl bestimmt
jeder dritte werte hier afd
ich denke mal viele auch aus dieser
region haben bestimmt aus protest
anderes gewählt als wie sonst gewählt
haben meine meinung und solange sich ja
nichts anderen wird wird auch die
entschlossenheit dazu nicht anders waren
wir schon lange hätte sich etwas ändern
müssen bei der jahrhundertflut 2002
stand die siedlung unter wasser 2013
schon wieder die anwohner hatte in einem
bebauungsplan vertraut nun wollten sie
schadensersatz vom freistaat oder
wenigstens dass er ihnen hilft beim
umsiedeln
beides hat das land abgeschmettert und
auf einen flug schutz verwiesen
den gibt es bis heute nicht vier
landtagswahlen sind seitdem verstrichen
alle politiker sanierung gesagt ja wir
helfen euch machen alles dafür dass
nichts passiert es ist jetzt
mittlerweile malen
planfeststellungsverfahren auf die beine
gestellt wurden aber demnächst sitzen
vielleicht die grünen mit einem
regierungstisch hier fürchten sie dass
deine flut schutz und naturschutz
konkurrieren cdu-kreisrat haug sieht als
nünchritz ein schwarz grünes bündnis
skeptisch das ist meine sorge dass das
nicht dazu beitragen wird dass die cdu
zu ihrer alten stärke zurückfindet weil
sie eben ihre eigenen themen nicht so
dann einbringen wird wie es eigentlich
nötig wäre
das könnte passieren erste wahlanalysen
heute im landtag die cdu wappnet sich
für schwierige koalitionsgespräche mit
den grünen beim thema energiewende
könnte man weiter nicht auseinander
liegen der redebedarf der grünen über
den braun kohlekompromiss nervt die cdu
schon jetzt und zu diesem kompromiss
mögen ist alle beteiligten auf einfach
stehen weil dieser kompromiss ist
ausgehandelt
und es trägt nicht zur glaubwürdigkeit
von politik bei wenn man einmal
getroffene entscheidungen und
kompromisse immer wieder in frage stellt
die grünen sind allerdings nur bereit
für diese koalition wenn der braunkohle
ausstieg jetzt beginnt der cdu und
ministerpräsident kretschmann muss klar
sein dass er viele leistungen bekommen
hat aus dem progressiven lager die hier
wirklich für eine veränderung und einer
erneuerung von sachsen angetreten sind
und ihm das vertrauen gegeben haben und
das müssen wir jetzt auch gemeinsam
umsetzen
jeder der möglichen koalitionspartner
der neuen sachsen regierung zieht also
schon mal rote linien hinter denen es
nicht weitergeht auch die spd
wir haben als spd sehr konkrete
vorstellungen auch davon die wir auch
wieder der mögliche koalition umsetzen
wollen das heißt es wird schwierig etwa
beim thema längeres gemeinsames lernen
die spd will das schon lange die cdu hat
es immer verhindert für gesprächsstoff
für den landesvorstand der cdu der heute
abend das dilemma dieser mal gespräche
jahre das lächeln wieder lernen dafür
haben sie nun fünf monate zeit dann muss
eine neue sächsische regierung stehen
in brandenburg gibt sich mit blick auf
die regierungsparteien gewissermaßen
eine spiegelbildliche situation hier
konnte sich die spd behaupten
ebenfalls besser als zeitweise
vorhergesagt aber am ende eben auch nur
mit mühe und verlusten
das amtliche ergebnis nach auszählung
aller stimmen sieht so aus spd 26,2
prozent
die afg 23.5 cdu nur 15,6 die grünen
10,8 die linke 10,7
die evb freie wähler schaffen es mit
fünf prozent in den landtag die fdp mit
4,1 hingegen nicht
das regieren in brandenburg wird
jedenfalls auch kompliziert für die
bisherige koalition reicht es hier auch
nicht mehr
alexander es richtet unterwegs mit
gregor weihs in strausberg berliner
speckgürtel eigentlich wollte der
36-jährige für die region in den landtag
einziehen doch seine partei die linke
hat ihr fast die hälfte ihrer stimmen
eingebüßt weil sie kein ohr hatte für
die probleme vor ort glaubt weiss das
haben leider auch einige unserer
spitzenpolitiker ausdruck gelebter man
passt sich dann ziemlich schnell an
an diese politische establishment seine
partei habe in den vergangenen zehn
jahren den kontakt zu den wählern
verloren
viele hätten sich nur noch mit einer
protestwahl zu helfen gewusst
besonders die menschen die vielleicht
das genau gegenüberliegende lage aus
enttäuschung gewählt haben gar nicht
weil sie der meinung sind ich bin jetzt
gegen ausländer oder sonstwas sondern
weil sie einfach gefrustet waren
enttäuscht waren gerade die menschen für
die müssen wir glaube ich da sein was
sich in strausberg in kleinen vollzug
erlebte die linke in ganz brandenburg
einen vertrauensverlust
heute ist von demo die rede und davon
dass zehn jahre rot rot die linke
unkenntlich gemacht hätten sich die
umfragen 70 unser wählerin nicht was
eigentlich die linke in dieser
regierungsbeteiligung durchgesetzt
also in die zukunft sämtliche
konstellationen die da auf dem sind
bedeutet dass konsequenter sein
noch weiß niemand wie diese
konstellation aussehen werden auch
dietmar woidke nicht mit der zuspitzung
des wahlkampfes wir oder die ard holte
die spd doch noch die meisten stimmen
braucht jetzt aber zwei
regierungspartner die cdu es von den
partnern die für uns infrage kommen
der stärkste partner wir brauchen eine
stabile regierung in brandenburg wir
brauchen eine regierung die das land
voranbringt einer der möglichen partner
hatte sich das anders vorgestellt ingo
senftleben wollte ministerpräsident
werden jetzt muss er das schwache
abschneiden der cdu verantworten und
bekommt druck aus seiner partei sich zu
bewegen
auch darum dass wir in brandenburg eine
vernünftige regierung auf die beine
stellen können und dass wir dann auch
das machen was wir versprochen haben
nicht
taten zählen lassen taten zählen lassen
um zu überzeugen
dort umfragen der forschungsgruppe
wahlen haben viele die afb gewählt um
den anderen parteien einen denkzettel zu
verpassen
in hirschfeld in südbrandenburg an der
grenze zu sachsen ist dieser denkzettel
besonders groß 1200 menschen leben hier
jeder zweite stimmte für die afd
das ist protest war ganz einfach
protestwahl ohne jobs kann man kaum noch
ein kind
darum geht es über tun dass frust gegen
den vielen ländern ausländer gibt es
hier kaum auch sei die region nicht
abgehängt sagt der örtliche amtsdirektor
die dass ärzte schulen und
einkaufsmöglichkeiten alles vorhanden
die ursachen seien anderer
es ist eine hohe unzufriedenheit mit der
landespolitik wir haben erlebt dass man
trotz unsere vielen stellungnahmen zum
landesentwicklungsplan unsere wünsche
und auch wirklich im
wachstumsmöglichkeiten überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt hat der
länderübergreifende plan orientiere sich
zu sehr an potsdam und berlin im kampf
um den landtag haben deshalb alle
parteien versprochen den ländlichen raum
zu stärken
doch vorher braucht brandenburg eine
regierung wie dieses dreierbündnis
aussehen wird weiß heute noch niemand
wie umgehen mit diesen wahlergebnissen
wie umgehen mit der afg darüber wollen
wir mit dem ministerpräsidenten von
sachsen-anhalt sprechen mit reiner
haseloff guten abend der hase läuft
guten abend nochmals diese
regierungsbildung und werden schwierig
sie selbst hinter gewissermaßen pionier
sie haben seit 2016 eine kenia koalition
die sich oft streit wird die schwierig
ist warum empfehlen sie ihren kollegen
kretschmer in sachsen dennoch diesen weg
zu gehen also koalitionspartner die
nicht um die beste lösung streiten
die sind keine demokraten das gehört
dazu und ich bin froh dass wir uns um
lösungen streiten können denn ich kenne
auch aus der ersten hälfte meines lebens
eine situation wo das nicht möglich war
also dass es erstmal keinen negativen
und wenn natürlich drei parteien
zusammenarbeiten müssen mit völlig
unterschiedlichen programmatischen da
muss man sehen wie die schnittmengen
aussehen die kann man durchaus
definieren und für eine
legislaturperiode hat man dann auch
genug projekte zusammen um gemeinsam
erfolgreich zu sein und wenn sie sich
unsere liste der verabschiedeten
gesetzen gesamt analytische frage es
sind immer ungeliebte koalitionen die da
umstellt werden um gewissermaßen die afg
zu verhindern
ob es eine große koalition ist ob es
solche dreier koalitionen sind die
einfach von den partnern heer von
vornherein schwierig sind
sehen sie nicht die gefahr dass man dann
auch der afd damit munition gibt zu
sagen da sieht man es ja das ist ein
kartell der altparteien und wir sind die
einzige opposition ein dilemma ich habe
glaube dass das nicht der fall ist ich
ja ich könnte zwei konstellationen die
habe ich auch schon mitgemacht und die
waren in teilen schwieriger
ich glaube es kommt nicht auf die anzahl
der koalitionspartner an sondern auf das
was man in einem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart und es geht nicht nur darum
die auf die zu verhindern sondern in der
mitte eine handlungsfähigkeit einer
regierung sicherzustellen und wenn die
union einen regierungsauftrag bekommt
wie in sachsen oder wie damals bei mir
und sachsen anhalt
kann sie genau schauen mit wem sie
zusammenarbeiten will und auch
letztendlich auch passend zusammen
arbeiten kann und mit wem sie das nicht
will und dass wir mit den linken keine
regierung bilden war klar dass wir mit
der afg keine regierung bilden wollen
ist klar und demzufolge waren noch zwei
parteien übrig und dann kamen wir
politische verantwortung gezeigt und
haben diese regierung gebildet ich bin
froh darüber
sehen sie keine gefahr dass das auch die
union zerreißen kann es geht eher um
ihrem landesverband stimmen die
eigentlich immer mit der afg
zusammengehen würden es gibt die gruppe
die so genannte werte union die
neuerdings viel von sich reden macht die
die grünen zum beispiel als linksradikal
ablehnt ja also da habe ich wie gesagt
eine klare meinung dazu
die parteien in der mitte und dazu zähle
ich auch die grünen das ist unser
koalitionspartner
das sind demokratische partei wir haben
viel miteinander umzugehen und
wahrscheinlich ist dass auch der umgang
miteinander der derzeit auch die
akzeptanz der demokratie gerade in den
ostdeutschen ländern auf 40 prozent hat
absinken lassen
das kann uns nicht zufriedenstellen auf
der anderen seite nicht nur auch ganz
klar sagen wir brauchen eine
handlungsfähige regierung und die
koalitionspartner die sich dort zusammen
raufen die haben dann auch eine
verantwortung und ich glaube dass jeder
nachvollziehen kann dass eine union
keine koalition mit der linken macht und
dass wir logischerweise mit unseren
hauptkonkurrenten darf die ebenfalls
nicht zusammenarbeiten und eine
regierung versuchen zu bilden
das geht nicht wir wollen ganz klar die
wähler von dort zurück holen die zur
aufgegangen sind sowohl aus dem
nichtwählerlager als auch abgewanderte
wählerinnen und wähler und dazu muss uns
mehr einfahren als bisher und das
versuchen wir bei uns als auch demnächst
wahrscheinlich in sachsen das seien
schwierig wähler zurückzuholen auch ein
kretschmer ist das ja nur bedingt
gelungen er hat sehr stark profitiert
von wählern gegen gewissermaßen
zähneknirschen die stimme gegeben haben
weil sie nicht wollten dass die afg
stärkste kraft wird
das ist richtig die mobilisierung
bereits das erste das klar ist dass die
große mehrheit nicht auf die gewählt hat
und zweitens dass die auf denen ich die
stärkste politische kraft sein kann
der nächste schritt ist dass das was wir
auch in den wahlkampf versprochen haben
beziehungsweise was generell auch
bundespolitisch die koalition in berlin
zu machen hat
dass das von erfolg gekrönt sein was wir
müssen jetzt liefern
den menschen ist jetzt auch zb beim polo
ausstieg und den strukturveränderungen
viel versprochen wurden das muss jetzt
kommen und daran werden die menschen uns
festmachen
und daran wird sich auch entscheiden ob
wir wählerinnen und bilder
zurückbekommen oder ob sie dauerhaft im
rechten spektrum auch verantwortung
bleiben
es ist ja nicht nur rechts das ist zum
teil rechtsextrem
der generalsekretär der csu hat jetzt
gesagt die afg sei sozusagen eine neue
npd das hat aber ein drittel der wähler
in sachsen und ein viertel der wähler
und brandenburg nicht abgeschreckt diese
extremistischen bezüge ist der
brandenburgische spitzenkandidaten
erklären sie sich das ja und das ist
unsere politische herausforderung genau
das ist das thema wir müssen das aber
mal gesamtgesellschaftlich diskutieren
wir wissen alle die auf de ist eine
westdeutsche gründung die führungsleute
auf der bundesebene kommen alle aus dem
besten sind dort sozialisiert und wir
müssen uns in ostdeutschland die frage
stellen warum sie bei uns so einen
großen resonanz boden finden
eine begründung dafür könnte sein dass
wir irgendeine transformation in den
letzten 30 jahren erlebt haben
die viele schlicht und einfach sozusagen
überfordert hat und wo wir auch klar
sagen müssen dass wir die lösungen
anbieten die die anderen blogger
versprechen aber gar nicht die
instrumente dafür haben an den
ergebnissen dessen was wir momentan auf
der bundesebene und auch in den ländern
hinbekommen wird sich entscheiden ob wir
diese rechte beziehungsweise
rechtsextreme partei da gebe ich ihnen
vollkommen recht noch dauerhaft im
spektrum haben oder ob wir sie zurück
drängen was mein innigster wunsch wäre
sagte ministerpräsident von sachsen
anhalt ich danke für das gespräch
das interview haben wir aufgezeichnet
die gestrigen wahl erfolge für die afg
sind nicht für alle in der partei anlass
zu ungetrübter freude zum einen weil das
ziel stärkste kraft zu werden nicht
erreicht wurde und es aktuell auch keine
aussicht darauf gibt das was in der
partei auch schon mal als
machtergreifung bezeichnet wurde in
absehbarer zeit zu realisieren
die andere frage ist wie es im internen
machtkampf der afg weitergeht der
brandenburger spitzenkandidat kallwitz
ein westdeutscher mit rechtsextremen
kontakten in der vergangenheit
macht keinen hehl aus seiner nähe zum
radikalen thüringer flügelmann türke der
in der partei von den einen verehrt von
anderen geradezu gehasst wird
becker hatte im sommer den
bundesvorstand der afb den kampf
angesagt damit gepackt bericht die afg
genießt heute sichtlich den auftritt vor
der presse die zu kritisieren doch
eigentlich längst zu ihrem markenkern
gehört doch es gibt wahlerfolge zu
verkünden dass unsere ärgsten gegner
müssen zugeben dass wir der strahlende
wahlsieger dieses wahlabends in beiden
bundesländern sind es gibt eine
bürgerliche mehrheit in diesem lande und
zu der gehören bier später zeigt sich
wie weit es mit der bürgerlichkeit
mitunter bestellt ist als die
journalisten der bundespressekonferenz
gegenüber andreas kalbitz
selbstverständliches betonen muss bevor
wir zur nächsten frage kommen möchte ich
vielleicht an diesem besonderen ort der
pressefreiheit einmal festhalten das ist
dass ich für unsere mitglieder in
anspruch nehmen dass wir keine schmäh
kampagnen machen dass wir kein fake news
verbreiten kalbitz hatte fragen zu
rechtsextremen kontakten in der
vergangenheit gereizt abgewehrt mit
rückendeckung des parteichefs
wir können von bezügen reden das hat
mich auch völlig offen eingeräumt
und der rest ist die fortsetzung dieses
narrativ und apolitisch da muss machen
doch nicht jeder in der afg sieht
rechtsextreme bezüge so gelassen
kalbitz als belastung natürlich war das
nicht hilfreich das ist völlig klar
und jetzt stelle man sich mal vor man
hätte jetzt wirklich respektable
personen sozusagen ohne jegliches keine
lösungsmöglichkeit in der afd
dann geht glaube ich die decke nach oben
offen doch gerade der rechtsaußen flügel
vom verfassungsschutz als sogenannter
verdachtsfall geführt sieht sich
gestärkt will nach den noch anstehenden
wahlen in thüringen aus den ostverbänden
heraus im bund mehr mitmischen
dann werde ich mich nach dem 27 zehnter
auch mit dem thema bundesvorstand
beschäftigen natürlich durch das und
natürlich möchte ich dass der osten auch
dort personell besser repräsentiert ist
das ist sicherlich eine konsequenz aus
diesen aus worden nein das sehe ich
nicht
der osten war schon immer stärker ähneln
in den wahlergebnissen
das hat sich hier jetzt nur nun nur
erneut widergespiegelt das ist auch die
installation eines machtkampfes zwischen
ost und west den ich von vornherein ich
mag selbst ein internes auf die
strategie papier warnt es gebe fünf mal
so viele potenzielle wähler im westen
wie im osten also wahlerfolge im osten
sind wichtig aber die bundesweiten
ergebnisse werden maßgeblich durch das
abschneiden im westen beeinflusst es
geht auch um rote linie die schleswig
holsteinische landesvorsitzende wurde
aus der partei ausgeschlossen vorwurf
unter anderem fördermitgliedschaft in
einem extremistischen verein doch
unterstützer wird er nun verrat an
gründungs idealen der afd aus lahnstein
hat die seele der partei damals
gestreichelt sie hat die emotionale
bindung zu einem großen teil der
mitgliederschaft ich sage jetzt mal am
morgen hatte er nicht dass hier
zumindest nicht objektiv vorgegangen
wird ja dass man die hier jetzt die
fürstin auf aufhängt anderen nichts tut
es hat doch mit sicherheit schon etwas
damit zu tun wie im hintergrund die
machtstrukturen laufen
ein aufruf hol dir deine partei zurück
fordert einen mitglieder parteitag mehr
macht für die basis am tag nach der wahl
geht es auch um identität und einheit in
der eigenen partei ausführliche
wahlanalyse und viele videos zu den
gestrigen landtagswahlen finden sie bei
uns natürlich auch online auf jetzt die
nachrichten noch ist nicht klar welche
zerstörungen genau der hurrikan dorian
auf den bahamas angerichtet hat aber die
verwüstung seit beispiellos meldet der
premierminister per kurznachricht
sturmböen von rund 300 kilometern pro
stunde und meter hohe flutwellen trafen
die inselgruppe südöstlich des us
bundesstaates florida
der hurrikan bewegt sich nur sehr
langsam weiter er tobte stundenlang über
den bahamas sein weiterer weg richtung
norden dort in den us-küsten regionen
bereitet man sich vor unter anderem mit
evakuierungen
der britische premier johnson will sich
in brüssel unter keinen umständen für
eine erneute verschiebung des eu
austritt einsetzen
der komme am 31 oktober ob mit oder ohne
austritt vertrags soll johnson zusammen
mit der opposition wollen aber einige
abgeordnete der regierungsfraktion
morgen im parlament einen austritt ohne
vertrag verhindern
sie forderte chancen auf seine
verhandlungsposition gegenüber der eu
nicht zu schwächen
laut medienberichten strebt die
regierung schnelle neuwahlen an sollte
das parlament ihre exit pläne in
hongkong hat es nach den teils schweren
auseinandersetzungen zwischen polizei
und demonstranten am wochenende heute
weitere protestaktionen gegeben
am ersten tag nach den ferien
boykottierten schüler und studenten den
unterricht demonstranten blockierten
züge
es kam zu verspätungen und in einem
krankenhaus formten streiken der
angestellte eine menschenkette zu den
finanzthemen dieses tages frank bethmann
dazu zählt auch die geplante
facebook-konto währung libra genau und
die kritik daran von der europäischen
zentralbank und zwar deutlicher denn je
bisher vertrat die ezb den standpunkt
libra ist für uns nach dem was wir
kennen keine währung nun wird der ton
schärfer ezb-direktoriumsmitglied yves
mersch spricht jetzt von einer gefahr
wenn man eine solche crypto die wiese
akzeptieren würde könnte die kontrolle
der europäischen zentralbank über den
euro sinken
denn im gegensatz zum euro oder dollar
werden crypto währungen wie bitcoin oder
lieber nicht von zentralbanken geschöpft
sondern von computernetzwerken
folgerichtig haben eben auch notenbanken
keine kontrolle mehr über crypto
währungen
diese kontrolle ist aus sicht der
notenbanken aber zwingend notwendig
andernfalls könnten die ezb und andere
zentral breiten nur noch bedingt die
zinsen und die im umlauf befindliche
geldmenge steuern
facebook will im kommenden jahr das
digital geld libra einführen
doch nicht nur von der ezb sondern auch
von den führenden industriestaaten gibt
es gegenwind frank bild man vielen dank
und der berliner zoo freut sich über den
ersten panda nachwuchs deutschlands an
der dahme mein mann hat am samstag
zwillinge zur welt gebracht
ihre schwangerschaft wurde erst vor
wenigen tagen entdeckt da große pandas
bei zwillingsgeburten meist nur ein
junges aufziehen wird man männlich vom
zu unterstützt und weil die eltern nur
aus china ausgeliehen sind muss ihr
nachwuchs laut vertrag nach rund vier
jahren dorthin zurück derweil rennen am
amazonas weiter die wälder das vom
brasilianischen präsidenten letzte woche
erlassene verbot des abbrennens von
flächen zeigt bislang keine wirkung im
gegenteil
das liegt auch daran dass der anreiz
waldflächen zu roden so groß ist dass
eine reportage von katrin eigendorf nur
wenige kilometer von porto value
entfernt spuren der zerstörung ein
weiteres stück regenwald das durch
brände vernichtet wurde
vor zehn jahren war der wald hier noch
intakt inzwischen verläuft eine schneise
mitten hindurch überall gibt es weiden
mehr als 25 prozent des regenwaldes sind
in london dem kleinsten bundesstaates
amazonas bereits vernichtet illegale
abholzung und brandrodung unterwegs
begegnen uns immer wieder laster die
holz abtransportieren
direkt an der schotterpiste hat es
letztens noch gebrannt
manuel hat hier sein kiosk er findet es
gut dass die europäer druck auf die
brasilianische regierung machen erzählt
er uns wenn wir den wald um uns herum
nicht bewahren wird alles zu wüste wir
werden keinen sauerstoff mehr haben weil
sie alles niederbrennen
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter über viele kilometer
zieht sich die piste durch den amazonas
rechts und links gerodete flächen an
vielen zäunen hängen schilder dann zu
verkaufen das geschäft mit dem regenwald
läuft denn brasilianische pharma
schaffen sich hier weideland und
ackerflächen
der regenwald unwiederbringlich zerstört
und seine familie sind vor 20 jahren in
den amazonas gezogen jedes jahr legen
die farmer in der gegend feuer aber so
schlimm wie in diesem jahr waren die
brände noch nie jetzt haben die
feuerwehr und die armee die feuerwehr
gelöscht vorher waren sie heftig die
leute die rinder haben gewinnen land in
dem sie es abbrennen der familienvater
zeigt uns ein haus das er selbst gebaut
hat dass die regierung brandrodungen 60
tage verbietet sei nicht wirklich ernst
zu nehmen meint er
schließlich können sie hier nur
existieren wenn sie den wald vernichten
es gibt jetzt ein bisschen weniger
brände aber es ist nicht vorbei das wird
jetzt viel gemacht deswegen muss man
vorsichtiger sein wenn die
aufmerksamkeit erst einmal vorbei ist
wird es weitergehen wir brasilianer
finden immer einen weg den wald
wirtschaftlich zu nutzen hat präsident
ball so nahe als ziel seiner politik
verkündet darauf setzen sie hier
auch in zukunft das war es von uns heute
und gleich gehts mit dem montagskino
weiter und um 0 uhr gibt es dann heute
plus mit daniel bröckerhoff der auf
wiedersehen bis morgen
[Musik]
und am liebe zuschauer im norden bleibt
wechselhaft im süden wird es morgen
sonnig und es wird ein bisschen wärmer
von westen kommt diese warme luft nur
durch dieses hochdruckgebiet ist dass
sie zu uns der luftdruck steigt
verdrängt die wolken hier im süden aber
leider nicht wie im norden die streifen
das küstengebiet
da wird ein bisschen drüber sein und ab
und zu eben auch mal nachts temperaturen
morgen gut 20 grad in mitteleuropa im
osten ist noch die hitze über der
ukraine am schwarzen meer im westen die
wärme mit 25 grad über frankreich ja und
bei uns werden die nächte frisch morgen
früh wieder fünf bis 13 grad in den
mittelgebirgen zum teil nur zwei grad
könnte auch mal bodenfrost geben
und letzte regentropfen jetzt im
südöstlichen bayern die lassen danach
verschwindet dagegen dafür kommt nach
mitternacht neuer regen an die nordsee
an der wind legt zu wird kräftiger
morgen haben starkem südwestwind dort
mit stürmischen böen über
norddeutschland weitere regenschauer die
nach osten ziehen im landesinneren
bleibt es meist trocken ist lockert mehr
und mehr auf und in der mitte und im
süden wechseln sonne und wolken und
teilweise ist der himmel auch wolkenlos
damit steigen die temperaturen noch ein
bisschen an meist haben wir 20 bis 26
grad nur im norden von schleswig
holstein und an der ostsee auf rügen da
wird es noch ein bisschen frischer sein
der mittwoch wird auf jeden fall noch
wärmer werden nur norddeutschland haben
wir schon kräftige schauer auch der wind
legt zuwider und am donnerstag und
freitag ist es deutlich kühler
wechselhaft mit schauern und auch
einzelnen gewittern ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie es
gut